there's one thing that no one wants to
say as part of that conversation that I
feel needs to be said which is it's not
true that everyone knows how best to run
their life what is true is that it's
preferable to behave as if that's true
and to bear the consequences of your own
bad decisions yourself
but we don't seem to ever air that part
of it we don't ever say you messed up
and now you're in debt and now you've
got to pay it off
right you messed up and you did this and
now you got to take responsibility and
if we're not willing to say that nothing
else works
this whole thing breaks down yeah that's
a really good point I think most people
know what's best for themselves and
their families I trust that you two know
what's best in your lives and that's
because you don't know as well right
yeah
um most people that you meet in the
public on the street you know you know
this from your own lives that people you
know people you know who are not in the
public eye at all they know what they're
doing they know how to raise their kids
most people do know but you raise a
really important point which is that
some people are stupid let's be honest
about it some people don't know they
make bad judgments
um but even that I think is part of the
Enlightenment Freedom that I'm talking
about right it's the right to make wrong
choices and actually Jon Stewart Mill
talks about this in on Liberty published
in the 1860s I think
um where he says that even if it's true
that the government has a better idea
than this person this this Dad or this
mum or this in this drunken on the
street even if it's true that there
government has a better view of that
person's life than that person
themselves still that person must be
allowed to make their own judgments
because only through the process of
making your own choices making your own
judgments making your own mistakes that
you might potentially learn something
and that you might actually correct
yourself and you might actually think I
need to improve and some people don't
some people just
I suppose let me just push back on that
so we spend a lot of time in America and
we love America but if you go to San
Francisco or any city in the United
States you see homeless people wandering
around drug addicted clearly incapable
of functioning on any level any level
whatsoever the argument is well it's
cruel to keep these people in you know
Mental Hospitals or drug counseling they
should be free to live their lives that
doesn't really work on a purely
practical level because what it leads to
is San Francisco yeah and that isn't
good for anybody
yeah or San Francisco as our mutual
friend Michael Schellenberg who calls it
I don't disagree I think there is a
point at which
um
the defense of Freedom becomes something
else it becomes the defense off
um self-destruction
it's very we have to be very careful in
working out where that line is but you
see it I've seen it in San Francisco
I've seen it in Los Angeles last time I
was in Los Angeles I was horrifying it's
every big city in America including in
red states by the way unbelievable I was
in Salt Lake City a few weeks ago that
there's just people wandering around
harassing people sitting Outdoors just
mentally ill people and they're not
they're not that's not Freedom no no
that's not freedom I agree and um I was
really shocked the last time I was in LA
isn't you know we have homeless problems
in London and we have poverty problems
in London but La is off the scale you
know there are tents and Tents and on
the streets and people living on the
streets you don't even know some of them
are alive or not you're literally
walking past people who could be dead
it's the it's third world conditions
it's it's really shocking you say that I
lived in the third world this does not
right right
in Russia in Ukraine in Armenia in
Uzbekistan I I've never seen anything
like this in the third world it's
horrendous there's no question about
that there are smaller scale versions of
it I think in Europe
um I go to Ireland a lot and I go to
Dublin on my way to to Galway which is
the place I mostly go to and even in
Dublin you'll see some of these problems
expressed in a smaller way you'll see
long user people from Methadone and so
on on certain streets and so there are
lots of problems
I think the issue there is that I think
some people confuse Freedom with
non-judgmentalism that's the problem and
so I am I I am a fervent defender of
freedom freedom of speech freedom of
choice freedom of conscience freedom of
Association the vast majority of human
beings should enjoy those freedoms and
have every ability to do so but there is
a section of society that who fall under
the radar or who who
um fall on hard times and I think what
contemporary Western Elites do is that
they use the language of freedom to
justify those people's self-destruction
so they say is there free choice relax
if they want to defecate in public and
shoot up in public and do whatever else
they want to do in public that's freedom
but that's not Freedom that's
degradation that is self-degradation but
it's also social degradation that
individual should not be experiencing
such horrific living conditions and the
other people in that Society whether
it's San Francisco or Dublin or whatever
else it might be should not have to
observe those living conditions so
that's another failure of solidarity
another failure of sense another failure
of reason and there are situations I
think extreme situations in which
society should make a judgment which is
very unfashionable these days and should
say we judge that these people their
behavior is so self-destructive and uh
also socially destructive that action
needs to be taken to try to get them on
the straight and narrow sometimes that
will work sometimes it won't but the
effort needs to be made but it's the
unwillingness to make judgments the
criminalization of moral judgment let
everything happen let everything go you
know don't be judgy that's I well once
you take away truth you take away right
and wrong and then you can't make a
judgment yeah exactly
foreign